welcome to barn finders my name is
markiplier
this is one of those games that looked
so goddamn ridiculous
is that definitely a copyrighted song
hang on wait no stop okay
nope stop okay that i literally
couldn't not buy it i couldn't tell you
the first
thing about this game censor that censor
me i don't get crude yet
you find barns
and you scavenge them for what looks
like
garbage in the trailer just play it
right now as i'm talking
put the volume down on that or real low
some of it is just
really looks like looks like garbage
right i think it's kind of like storage
wars where you be
i don't know is this
it'll explain itself or it won't you are
not
[Music]
oh
what are you doing
[Music]
[Music]
oh
this is definitely a copyright song you
gotta replace that but
i regret nothing about this purchase
this is incredible
okay all right
wake up young and our generator is down
okay
can you oh my god music can you stop
i turned you off hi what's up look
work awful hard our vacation awaits
your poster here it should work
okay i need to collect myself because it
is not
i cannot lose it this soon okay recycle
sure okay is i don't know if i'm
supposed to just start recycling
everything in my
uh in my house just yet but uh probably
not
hello oh all right cool man
uh what did i need to do wha
what was uh what was required of me i
actually don't remember
all right i'm going whatever it was oh
well it was beautiful for a second and
now i'm looking at this shitty piece of
paper
get car battery from the car's truck put
it into the generator use your computer
to find jobs and travel all over america
that is god damn gorgeous that's too
pretty for what this game is
that ain't right i'll tell you what
recycle recycle man all this money just
sitting around
no one's doing nearly enough get out of
the way here see this is what i mean
like the game seems like it's actually
i'm sorry
oh weird how that goes into the mystical
void that is my uh
whole truck but oh okay
sure what oh
okay we're gonna pretend like that
didn't happen got it
new mail whatever that means uh
well i mean i think i know what that
means what is it what did i get a floor
i got a whole ass
floor on the ground that's usually where
floors are
no i'm not gonna question it i'm being
too hello
i found a wall in a trash can that makes
sense okay
hi edward trafford
employee of the month great good stuff
all right nice
what was i supposed to do next big shelf
purchase upgrade tool
i don't have that i don't have that how
do i have that
i do not have enough money from all this
recycling that i'm doing so how do i
have that oh yeah the computer here we
go
barnhub you say
wow okay item cattle
that's scary um antiques i don't know
man
comics i got something oh
well call your mom good one
mega enlarge it's not a trick to get it
bigger try
our winnie bonnie energex pills
available now
we have more than 18.985 american men
amazed by their winning growth
barn can you help us i heard there's
still a naughty stag at that old red
barn could maybe
there's money okay you know what sure
all right let's do it the red barn
okay bye gas travel one
good thing i did all that recycling oh
my god
there's no roads did you just choose not
to go on a road or was there are there
literally no roads
hello
[Music]
all right i guess we're getting into the
game proper now which means i go through
this and uh
love nest nest of love who you loving
here
cool i'ma look in your love barn
let's explore around and take all sh
get to work are you gonna do anything
are you gonna sit on that
and you're just gonna arrest your loyals
by your uh your chicken i don't want to
talk to you as a funny thing i actually
want nothing to do with you okay am i
strong
how strong my god i'm so i'm incredible
ow wait hold the phone
where's the sun there's no sun
in the sky it's bright no sun
okay i'm gonna go in the barn now i want
to run as fast as i can what the hell
was that
what you're not going to explain that
probably for the best definitely for the
what am i doing
why would i be doing this
what is that who are you now
[Applause]
what is happening what's happening i've
never been more scared in my life that
explosive barrel it sure does look like
it doesn't it
okay why is this
why is why is this why is this mystical
silo
being mystical is there someone in there
uh you know what i i'm so stunned
by this game at every single turn but i
am having
an incredible time oh i see
is that a big old okay not what i
intended to do okay there's definitely
goodie up there someone get to it and i
need one more
thing you'll do you you you will do
bam okay i think this will do come here
you yeah okay
wow toilet paper gold toilet paper
i uh i deserve that one yeah i deserve
that
that makes complete sense all right
what's uh
the tippy top of the nothing okay cool
good
what
what what
i love it i love it
i'm crying i'm crying i love it this is
the greatest game
ever made in the history
history
stand up straight how how how oh my god
how
no no no no
yes no yes
there you are there you are friend
okay that's all i need i'd pick up in
three two
one schabowski nice well done
hello anybody in here no okay good
all right glad i went all the way to the
back for absolutely
nothing honestly i don't even know what
i'm looking for but
i'm sure it'll jump out at me when i
find it
thank you for the easy money thank you
yes easy who needs books not me
not me at all you gonna work
buddy all right cool yeah thanks man
man big cobwebs probably big spiders but
i'm not gonna worry too much about it
usable added one gas love that
that's nice why is that something there
nah it's just
sun rays from the you know sun
okay picking that up uh yeah yeah yeah
that'll do
i don't have a key what do you mean i
don't have a key break it open
use your big muscles you can get whoa
i love him
the greatest unsellable i don't care
i need that in my life in incredible
okay okay i got the key oh rope yeah
that'll do
keep done deal easy peasy
please squeeze me bundle of sticks
that's useless oh wow
wow uh would you look at that
sunny cat a fantastic sunny cat
life-size phenomenal taxidermy
craftsmanship
at his pose standing on a custom wood
base
yeah no kidding that is stunning okay
take this out of there
get that there valuable nah
all right how that wouldn't have held
those
well you know what whatever it's not
important not not
not the priority here not the priority
ladder up okay so there is an up there
oh
what's going on here oh my god
oh my god oh my god
nope nope whoa
a yamaha a jamaha body okay cool
good uh can i just climb
okay ooh
poster comic page oh
all right surely love is an inflatable
160 centimeter plastic sex doll produced
and designed
by frank goat corp since 1967.
wow great we'll take that apparently
how are they whoa well there she is
oh hey bud how you doing
wow look at that look at that whoever
was doing taxidermy in these parts
incredible oh god this is the love shack
[Music]
okay got it how are still so many items
remaining
that makes little to no sense during my
admittedly
i was just a fresh-born baby uh when i
first got in here
and now i feel like i've leveled up an
experience infinitely and i know exactly
the depths of depravity that this game
is going to send me careening into but
also i might not have noticed any items
that actually were of value on my first
pass-through so uh you know what uh
i i'm gonna keep looking buddy i'll keep
exploring small yeah i'm gonna do that
oh wheelbarrow that that looks looks
like a thing yeah
joe manure yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay there's at least one more big item
left so i just got to find that and then
we can
moosie out of here i don't know why i'm
pressed to be completionist about this i
shouldn't be
oh oh there it is baby
[Applause]
okay i've searched everywhere in this
barn and i mean
everywhere i've looked in every nook
every cranny
i cannot find what the last item is and
i don't think it matters so i'm just
gonna get out of here else i'll be here
for
like i was here as long as i played the
whole game just trying to get so
just gonna go forget about it human
specimen
what i will spawn random
uh okay cool items nine or ten yeah i
don't know where
it would have been but okay whatever hey
i'm gonna move on to the rest of the
game because there's another half of
this game about
selling all this stuff and i'm gonna
haggle i'm gonna haggle with people
i'm gonna haggle them up a storm how to
run your pawn shop
unload the truck by pressing the button
on the storage station that's handy use
secondary action button to place items
on the shelves automatically
handy open the shop during the day to
start selling items even handier okay
push the button
boink
what the hell did you jump in you okay
buddy i'll go to bed
i'm done here where's my bed
hey i see you up there what are you
doing up there stop being up there what
are you doing you think you can hide
from me how do i i got no junk how can i
stacks aha
you cannot hide from me you literally
cannot hide from me i will find you in
the darkness
i will come for you at night
taking this with me just in case just in
case i need it
oh look at that i didn't need it at all
all right good i got that i don't know
what that does for me
what just happened over there you wanna
run that by me again when ready to go to
sleep at the janitor's room
am i the janitor just a janitor
not that there's anything wrong with
that
i hate this is my hi
i do not want to talk to you i actually
really don't want to talk to you
going to sleep no one oh okay
for once it wasn't a fart that's strange
[Music]
what a thing to dream about okay new
mail good i can't believe we get
internet out here
click on the client to start selling you
can sell decline or haggle for a better
price when you haggle don't be too
greedy or you might lose some money
okay we're open for business we are open
hey look at this shop
this is looking pretty spiffy oh
how did you get here can i help you sir
oh but please we have to
haggle for it
nice i really want it's okay
all right you can have it i'm not gonna
be too greedy weird
agent person but we sold that so that's
good
welcome to mikko shop
[Music]
oh man i'm so close to getting both of
those ah
damn it oh damn it damn it i'm gonna do
the
axe because i've heard that i can get
more scrap from that and then i'm gonna
do the
light because that's gonna help me find
things once i do this job i'm going to
be
great bid event a new tournament that
mikko's bid wars just started let's go
to the bridge storage and win this the
one around give us tickets to hawaii
if you find a car engine there send it
cousin kevin okay
sure i don't have i just
spent my money
fine fine i get to go back to the same
place i
just was at to get more
money where's my ax yes please give
yeah i know we can but i'm not gonna
give me that
give me that is that good look at this
look at this that's some good
whatever hose wire great good
stuff love it yeah whatever this looks
bad to hit i won't do it then
bam wonkas frumpus bam junk
this would be bad to hit oh i thought it
was gonna but it didn't you know it
threw me for a loop there
hello uh where's this mysterious item
that i wasn't able to get
anybody know anybody heard of it anybody
know what i'm talking about
anybody is it good or bad i have no idea
oh
was that it black magic manual
was that it oh my god there are still
so many items how where what and how
how how how how
how how how where why there's
how oh
that's how oh got him apparently
all right good let's go home hey hey bud
let's go home you can mount an item
using other items
don't want to know about it i guess i go
to sleep then so i can sell my stuff
i'm gonna put a poster on a wall i can't
go to sleep now apparently
wow yeah that's good stuff wow
yeah good stuff man good stuff wednesday
oregon kebab vietnam
what okay whatever who wants to buy a
hose
tank black magic manual which seems
really
interesting oh my god
hi sure let's haggle
sounds fair good good good you're
welcome you're welcome buddy
who wants more we got more i need more
money come on we got to get more money
come on get the money get the money now
i want the money now you better pay me
my money
no one's paying me any money i don't
care i guess we're good there
oh hey how you doing hey what's up
hey you want to buy something well
you know ah yeah
oh yeah you can pay that of course thank
you for your business
i really appreciate it you have a lovely
day now have fun with that tank i'm
definitely sure it's full of fuel and it
was definitely worth that price okay
we're going
okay yes
i like how all of america is that part
of america
is that a horse that's a tank
or was it a horse oh cool hey how you
doing
well this is all variable okay mikko's
special van
okay all right uh hi oh
your goal is to be the highest bidder
you small and big bit i don't have that
much
money i don't have i'm not like hi
your uncle smells like a drunken pig
thanks
living back with your uncle that's some
great news brethren
okay all right is there anything on the
roofs roofs
i'm not ready shut up gotta collect sodi
cans
oh oh i hear
oh oh
all right now i'm ready i'm ready now
now is when i'm ready
migo is a real face of america
that six hundred dollars i owe you kick
their eggs
oh wow thank you that helps a lot
i will bid
on
oh i did win oh i forgot that was me i
actually forgot that that's what that
looked like but hey
suck it all of you you all are terrible
people and i hope
that you have a lot of traffic on the
way back home
and i hope your dinner gets burnt in the
microwave i did it i did it uncle i did
it uncle i did it
i did it i did it unk before we go
breaking anything let's just make
absolutely sure that everything of value
is gotten first
oh jama engine i can make a drama
all right whoa what did i just get that
looks explosive and dangerous
hell yeah well so far so good am i
so good i mean basically usually storage
doesn't have basements
whoa
oh oh oh oh oh oh
okay i didn't even know that i needed
that for that but i got it okay thank
you
wow excellent good thing i have a light
excellent
hubcaps are good i guess probably build
a vehicle out of that
thanks uncle very strong anyone ever
tell you that
whoa
finish the map oh
damn look at all this stuff
dude i hit the gold mine dude
oh there's more which is very strange
oh look at this thing yeah gas
dude this is awesome is that a jamahoo
wheel i only need one more of those i
got a full on jump huh
name why can't i take the air
conditioner hello
hi how are you doing long hard and funny
that's what they call me that's what
i've been called before
many times whoa
hi oh yeah engine i needed that okay
well that couch looks good can i have it
[Music]
damn well i mean this is going my oh i
love him
i love i love him
yeah okay i did it time for epic
destruction
time for me to wreak havoc on this poor
poor place
sorry sorry sorry
i got everything i needed therefore
everything is dispensable
disposable is that blood
hmm that i'm not gonna worry about it
looks like i don't worry about hitting
explosive barrels okay everything has
been destroyed in here
i think i got everything pretty sure
anyway
see you around buddy see you around hey
i'll see you around i'll see you around
buddy i'll see you around what do i need
all the scrap for i have
no idea but i'll see hey what up losers
hey
nerds sounds unusual let's grab some
drinks later dude
you talk differently on occasion okay
let's get out of here we're okay good
hey hey
that was a what hot way this time what
what just happened how did you get how
what
apparently not important i'm not gonna
worry about it because that would take
too much brain power
all right hey buddy guess who got your
engine among other things but you don't
need to worry about that
hey thanks for the money idiot you know
my loser
i'm gonna give myself an upgrade
yeah whatever man hey thank you for the
upgrade gun you can customize your pawn
shop build
stations to clean repair and assemble
okay cool
that's what the scraps are for sorry to
repair of course that makes complete
sense
oh okay that was much less fantastic
than i thought it was going to be
all right i got a cleaning station i
don't know what that does drop item to
start the cleaning
uh where's an item you got an item
you had items build a shelf
old birdie
i can't afford any of it i guess i'll go
to bed then
the fascinating thing that i'm starting
to realize is that this game is actually
pretty
pretty interesting it's well made it's
interesting
funny sometimes and uh it's got me
talking in a bit more of a draw than
usually would do ah what are you doing
here don't look at me with that face
yeah that one how do i get out hello
welcome to my store how are you what
would you like
radio huh well
apparently easy to haggle with you
really want it so okay
all right you can have it thanks i don't
know where you disappear to
but please come back and buy more i want
to take items from
hello hello hello
hi hello oh god hi
you're back what can i do you for
what could do for oh well i can't just
let that go
all right it's a little much but yeah
okay all right thank you come again
all right uh this is not floating
anymore which is
okay there we go okay ah
okay i got it hi
ho hey okay
don't go don't go don't go hey what's up
hey how are you doing hey
oh man that's
a good price but listen we yeah thank
you all right hey
maybe a little more
your final offer hey you know it's okay
i get that i get that take it take it
off my hands
i want you to have it sucker idiot
fool two thousand dollars two thousand
dollars
i gotta clean this [ __ ] this clean yet
i can't tell what's there like a
specific part of this is dirty
object cleaned in 100 okay it's
apparently
it's done hey what's up hey you're back
uh good to see you i i got a fresh cat
perfectly clean yeah i gotta do a little
more
okay good yeah yeah you you gotta do
that yeah yeah okay um
can i put this on there directly do i
put it back in storage or s
something hello i
did it what else is dirty only the sex
doll which is obviously important
oh yeah [ __ ] and spam
[ __ ] spam [ __ ] and spam
hello welcome back hey you back hey i
knew you'd be back
yeah well that's tough i have to
have to ask for more yeah you can pay
that good good good
okay all right get out of here i know
what you want next just give me a second
it'll be ready
the object is clean baby clean put that
back in the old
what's him who's it there we go and then
i put it
here i'm getting oh no sex doll
maybe it's too big hey
hey you would want that wouldn't you
poink oh maxed out i know
cool man cool welcome to mikoshop
i know there's another place here for
the
okay build items from parts transfer
some storage or drop items by hand
how do i do how do i do that how do how
do i
how do i do that how
i guess i just do it by hand
[Music]
uh
[Music]
do
[Music]
okay now you work okay
now it's all right
there it is wow
okay all right that took a long time and
a lot of effort to figure out exactly
how that was supposed to go but whatever
we got it so
i think that's enough for barn finders
for me it's actually a fun game
i'm i'm kind of surprised 9 out of 10.
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to play in the description
as always find it on steam or whatever
it's oddly enough kind of fun so enjoy
it let me know what you thought down in
the comments below
have you ever found a barn before i
don't know tell me
i'll probably listen but thank you and
as always i'll see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you